Speaker 1: OK, so one story from Stephanie
Gresham's new book, I'll Take Your Questions Now
is Trump opted not to receive anesthesia, general
anesthesia or deep sedation for his colonoscopy
in twenty nineteen because he didn't want to
temporarily give presidential power to Mike
Pence. OK, that's story number one. The second
story told by Stephanie Grisham, which we're going
to look at now, is, I believe, far more disturbing
because it again is more of a another data point
in this. Smeeton this I don't know if that's a
word in Trump being smitten with authoritarians
like Vladimir Putin. Stephanie Grisham writes
in her new book that Donald Trump told Putin
privately, I'm going to have to act a little
tougher to you in public for the cameras. OK,
Salon's John Skolnick wrote about this yesterday.
Donald Trump reportedly assured Vladimir Putin
that he had to act, quote, a little tougher next
to the Russian president, quote, for the cameras,
according to a forthcoming book by Trump's
White House press secretary. The book,
I'll take your questions now by Stephanie Grisham
details. A host of Never Before Seen insights into
Trump's relationship with Putin brings to light
a number of more bizarre personal requests,
his terrifying temper and strains in his
relationship with the former first lady, Melania
Trump. According to The New York Times, the former
president went out of his way to please Putin,
telling the Russian leader during the
twenty nineteen Osaka summit, the G20,
that he would put on a display of machismo.
But just for show, Trump reportedly told Putin,
with all the talk of sanctions against Russia
for interfering in the 2016 election and for
various human rights abuses, I'm going to act
a little tougher with you for a few minutes,
but it's for the cameras. And after they leave,
we'll talk, you understand. In another instance,
Grisham also claims Trump joked with Putin about,
quote, getting rid of journalists who produce,
quote, fake news, telling him you
don't have this problem in Russia.
While The Washington Post got a copy of the book,
it details tensions between Trump and his wife,
Melania, who, quote, unleashed her contempt
for her husband amid reports that his attorney,
Michael Cohen, paid adult film star Stormy Daniels
to keep quiet about their affair. It was during
this personal debacle that Melania reportedly
grew much closer, with Grisham telling her
that she didn't believe her husband's denials
of the affair. Oh, please. Are you kidding me? I
don't believe any of that. This is the equivalent.
So I don't care about the Melania stuff.
Trump saying to Putin, I'm going to have to
pretend to be a little tougher with you for the
cameras. But we're going to talk. Everything's
fine. This is the equivalent of bombing Syria,
quote, bombing Syria, but telling Putin ahead of
time and bombing an empty runway which was back up
and running within hours. Now, I was not for the
escalation of tensions with Syria. I don't mention
that anecdote because I'm saying Trump should have
really crushed Syria. That's not what I'm saying.
It's an example of the subservience of Trump
to Putin. It's not about they were in a room
together plotting this or that. We never believed
that that was the case. It's not about the quote,
collusion with Russia was going to be so proactive
that it was going to remove Trump. That was never
the case. Go to my clip, say, April 2017, where
I'm telling you that this is about the level of,
again, Trump being smitten with people like
Putin and just enamored and sucking up to them.
The other funny little detail is that if this is
true, if Trump did tell Putin, I'm going to have
to act tougher in front of the cameras, you have
to. But don't worry, it's not going to be real.
Trump didn't really act tough with Putin in
front of the cameras. I think there was like,
you know, I asked him about the hacking and he
said they didn't do it. That's acting tough.
What are you even talking about? Like, if that
was Trump acting tougher with the cameras on,
imagine the level of suck up brownnosing
that was taking place behind the scenes.
And it's just become so clear in
the time since Trump has left office
that Putin and the Russians, they are really
good at this stuff. They really are. It's not me
taking a position. It's just Putin and the
Russians know a perfect mark when they see one.
And Trump is just the perfect mark. This shouldn't
be surprising to anybody. I saw a funny comment,
which was, you know, we've had more on
presidents before. We've had cowardly
presidents before. But a moron cowered in Trump's
configuration was really a unique combination.
You could say that as far as the Grisham book
goes, she she's a disgruntled, another disgruntled
former person who you can't believe anything she
says. Maybe, maybe. But that remains to be seen.
And so far, everything that's been reported as
being in her book from the advanced copies that
The New York Times in The Washington Post got,
it all is very, very much on Brand. We'll take
a quick break. When the book is finally
out, we'll have much more from it, I'm sure